it just seems like it was yesterday
walking through the projects diving for
the knuckleheads seems like it was
yesterday standing in the workaround my
mom and my mom say you get a job I could
help you get our Walker remember that
I swear to you it is gonna change your
life and there's jobs waiting because
those jobs that can't be filled right
now
y'all iPhones huh you can make phones
with a science degree I made my own
following than a foot on my wrist ha
I got email a STEM education science
technology engineering and mathematics
get you to be able to do anything you
wanted it'll change not just your life
but your family's life and your neighbor
his life in your kid's life
not for nothing that everybody's here at
this time we're here for reason and
young people my purpose it's not about
me it's about you all achieve in your
goals and dreams I know in the wake of
the tragedy that happened nine months
ago in our community a lot of our
visitors you've seen a lot of stuff on
the news you seen a lot of stuff but I'm
telling you now you know you out of
tragedy
we have greatness we have a bust for all
the kids who want to join us to the
first of our championship so you can see
in person these robots these kids and
they're building these incredible
machines and we want to come back next
year and see you guys there too with
your robot so we're putting a challenge
right now looking at the way it's
changed our low community back in East
LA and really think it can happen
what's that family my name is Cynthia
and us I am in the eleventh grade and I
come from Roosevelt High School and in
Los Angeles from to you for you 1964 the
LA Street Bus will grow up and the
community that we come from so we'll it
was like I want to make a change and I
feel like this is you know it's gonna be
the future and I want my students to be
involved this made a huge difference for
me because I've always been into
engineering and computers and stuff like
that
technology is consistent and growing and
they're looking for younger audiences
they have a unique way of thinking and
getting younger audiences in would help
grow engineering technology and
everything what I want Ferguson students
to know is that no matter where you come
from no matter how bad things can be
sometimes it is possible to do what you
want